DAVID KINCH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd be happy to
answer any questions
I can about myself or,
more excitingly, the book
or the restaurant or
any of the projects
we're involved in, and
especially about the book.
The book has done
very well so far.
It's been released
for about two weeks.
It's been a labor of love.
It's taken about
15 months of work.
It is a book that
we did, actually,
much to the
publisher's surprise,
we did on time and
on budget, which
they tell me is quite rare
in the publishing industry.
And even though it is a
story of the restaurant,
people ask what the
cookbook's about.
It's really not a cookbook,
but a story of the restaurant.
We're about 12 years old now.
And I say it's a story
of the restaurant
as told through narrative
photographs and recipes.
And when we first decided to do
the book, the first thing I did
is I went through the
archives of all the dishes
that we had done for
the past 11 years.
And there were a lot.
We kept everything in file.
And I was really excited.
I thought, we'll
document the history
of the restaurant and our
evolution to the restaurant.
And I found that looking
through everything,
that I was not impressed
with-- in fact, embarrassed
with a lot of the previous
work that we had done.
And we had agreed to do photo
shoots over a 15-month period
so we could capture all the
seasonal nuances-- the seasons,
but also the seasonal
nuances-- throughout the year
and be able to capture the
full range of ingredients
that we work with
at the restaurant.
And it ended up turning out that
the dishes that we decided on
were all the current dishes
that were on the menu,
during the 15
months that we shot,
to the point where when
I look at the dishes
that we shot a year
and a half ago,
I see a certain amount
of datedness into it
and wondering why we were
doing those in the first place.
So about 10% of the recipes
are signature dishes.
There's recipes that have
kind of come and gone.
There's certain
dishes that we do
throughout the year in
season that we really
like and the restaurant
has become known for.
So those are
represented in the book.
But even though it is a story of
the history of the restaurant,
the actual recipes
and photographs
represent the past 15
months in our evolution.
There is a reason
for that, I think.
In thinking about
why that happened,
there's a part of
the book in which we
talk about cuisine
being a dynamic.
Food being such an inherent part
of our culture, whether we know
it or not-- there's the cliche
of food, clothing, and shelter.
How we nourish ourselves,
how we feed ourselves,
how we energize our
bodies to do what we do
is such an ingrained part in
the human psyche and our culture
that sometimes, we
take it for granted.
And here in the
United States-- I
consider myself an American
cook, an American chef,
even though a lot of my
training has been outside
in much more diverse and
rich culinary cultures.
But it's very nascent.
It's very young here
in the United States,
but we are growing, and we are
maturing really, really fast.
Cuisine is a living,
breathing endeavor
that is extremely dynamic.
It is constantly changing
and moving forward.
And that's what
happens with the food
that we do at the restaurant.
Say we're working with something
like asparagus in springtime.
There might be dishes
that we really like.
And then when it comes
around to springtime again,
and great asparagus
becomes available to us,
we have many options.
We can create the dishes that we
did the year before or the year
before that or the
year before that,
or we can create
completely new dishes
based upon the cultural--
based upon the reference points
and the data points
that we have gathered
throughout the year and the
experiences that we learned.
Or we can take that exact
dish, and we can build upon it.
So-called, we can improve it.
The point is, is
that it's not static.
It is dynamic.
And I think any
kind of endeavor,
especially with food,
what I do for a living,
if we become static-- we
don't evolve, we don't change,
we don't try to improve
ourselves on a daily basis-- we
will wither and die,
especially in such
an intensely competitive
atmosphere as the restaurant
and hospitality industry
in the Bay Area.
A great example of
cooking, about dynamics
and static or passive,
is, to use an example,
would be what is a static
or passive dessert?
A slice of a tart, a fruit tart,
could be considered passive
because you make the
tart in the afternoon.
You make it the day before.
And then when it's
ready to serve,
you cut a slice of the tart,
and you put it on a plate,
and you serve it.
And it's great.
It's a wonderful dessert.
But it's also the same on
Tuesday as it is Wednesday
as it is Wednesday at 4
o'clock in the afternoon
to the first piece
you serve at 6:30
and to the piece you
serve at 9:30 at night.
A dynamic dessert, a
real fundamental example
would be a dessert that is
finished with a scoop of ice
cream, because the ice
cream is on the plate,
and then five minutes
later, it's half melted,
and it has changed.
And it's completely evolved.
It's completely devolved.
That is a dynamic dessert.
That is a dish
that you're trying
to create that is best to be
enjoyed in the maximum flavor,
and its maximum
effect on the client
is within a specific window.
And this requires a certain
amount of labor and practice
and cooperation amongst
different parts of the kitchen.
And that's one reason
why dynamic desserts
are more expensive.
It's not necessarily because
of ingredients or anything
like that.
But you're paying
for the labor for it.
So that is a good example.
One last thing I want to mention
before we can go to questions
is-- maturation of a
chef, modernist cuisine,
the power of media
in my industry.
It used to be when I started
out as a young line cook,
nobody knew the
name of the chef.
We were domestics.
We worked behind the scenes.
If anybody knew anybody's name
in the restaurant business,
it was the owner of the
restaurant or the maitre d'.
And it's changed
dramatically over the years.
Over the past couple of decades,
chefs have become famous.
They've become much more
celebrity-conscious.
And I don't necessarily
think that is a good thing.
It has lured people into the
industry for the wrong reasons.
It used to be
cooking was a craft.
It was a middle-class craft.
It would be almost like
blacksmithing or learning
how to weave or working with
tapestries, in which you learn
certain skills, minutiae,
attention to detail,
and you did them over and over
and over again until you could
just pick up an onion, and
without thinking about it,
without looking at
it, you'd peel it,
and you'd cut into
quarter inch dice,
and your cutting
board would be clean,
and you have a pile
of waste, and you
have the pile of onions.
There was no thought
process behind it.
You just did things.
And you spent years perfecting
these rote, small minutiae,
details, and then you
advanced up through a kitchen.
And it was a craft.
Were there artistic elements?
Yes, there was always
artistic elements.
But there was never
really artists.
Artists come along
only once a generation.
Not everybody's an artist.
So it was always a craft
with artistic sensibilities.
Nowadays, I think
a lot of people
are attracted to the
industry because they
feel that it's
incredibly glamorous.
I can tell you,
I'm 52 years old,
and I still work 'til
1:30 AM in the morning,
and there's nothing
glamorous about that.
I work weekends.
I work nights.
I work holidays.
I work when you all
have time to go out
and eat at nice restaurants.
That's what we do.
So the final maturation
in a chef is not
when things are brand
new and you see things
that you've never seen
before, or you're bedazzled,
or the media tells you a dish
or new restaurant is great.
The last thing that happens
in a chef's development, when
they are mature, when
they're confident
in their own
abilities, when they're
confident in their
style, is that they're
cooking the most simple
food they've ever
cooked in their entire
life because they
are confident in
their technique,
in their perfection
of their technique.
They're buying the best
possible ingredients, which
they can buy because any chef
worth their salt will tell you,
the single most important
thing in cooking
is always buying the best
possible quality product
that you can afford, which
usually means catching things
at the peak of their season,
because they're at their best
and at their cheapest,
a win-win situation,
and then gently
nudging them forward
to where they are showing
at their very best.
Any flim-flammery,
wizardry, gimmickry
that covers up the inherent
beautiful qualities
that nature gives us is
usually the last thing
jettisoned by an immature cook.
A lot of molecular gastronomy
and gimmickry you will find
is mostly chefs who are
trying to impress other chefs
and not necessarily offering
the best possible experience
to you, the paying clients.
So that's really all I have to
tell people at Google today.
I'd be happy to answer
any questions that you
might have about the book or--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID KINCH: He's asking why I
felt that now is the best time.
It wasn't completely
my decision.
I had been wanting to write a
cookbook for the longest time.
I had written several
proposals over the years,
even with the same publisher
who eventually accepted us.
And I was always rejected
for whatever reasons.
And then the third
time, it was accepted.
And in conversations
with them, he
told me that, well, now the
restaurant had a story to tell,
now that I had a story to tell.
And it was interesting
because I really
fought to put the
proposals together.
Everything was kind of forced.
And it was, you know,
OK, I have a restaurant,
and people are starting to
hear about the restaurant,
so my next step is
to write a cookbook.
I have to do this.
And then I just kind
of forgot about it.
And then when the final
proposal was accepted,
it kind of happened
really naturally
and really organically.
And a lot of the comments
that we receive about the book
is that there is a
naturalness to the book that's
reflective of the restaurant and
what we do at the restaurant,
that it wasn't forced.
It wasn't like it was
time to write a cookbook.
It was a cookbook that is
naturally telling our story.
So I think it was
more of a feeling,
just things fell into place.
I found the right photographer.
The writer who I really wanted
to work with all of a sudden
became available and wanted
to be involved in the project.
And of course, it was
accepted by a publisher
whom I have great respect for.
Do I have a favorite
season in mind?
If I had to pick one,
it would probably
be right now, the
fall, because we
have the best of-- the
bounty of summertime,
but we're starting to move into
a little bit-- we can start
cooking with red meats again.
Red wine comes into play, cooler
nights, that sort of thing.
But the great
thing about cooking
seasonally is you cook
with all the bounty
of a particular season.
And right when you're getting
really bored or tired of it,
you're moving out
of it, and you're
moving to new and
more exciting things.
And then for nine months, you
don't have to worry about it.
And when things come around into
the cycle, you're re-energized.
You're re-energized
and think about things.
I like cooking all
times of the year.
Believe it or not, my least
favorite time is summertime.
Everything's so
leafy and tomatoey.
It's frivolous, which is nice.
It's nice.
It's nice for three months.
But it's not my favorite.
Every year we do
a tomato dinner,
where every course
has tomatoes in it.
And actually, it's a celebration
to celebrate the relationship
I have with Love Apple Farms,
which is the farm that we work
with who supplies
much of the produce
to the restaurant year round.
And she was originally a
champion tomato grower.
I first originally
bought tomatoes from her,
before we expanded
the relationship.
And tomatoes are still a very
big part of what she does
and how she does it.
So every year, we do it.
And we try to change
the dishes up.
So it's getting harder
and harder right now
to try and not repeat dishes.
We're trying to create
our tomato desserts.
We're like on our
10th tomato dessert.
It's really hard at this point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID KINCH: She's
asking what dishes
I've seen evolve over
the years and how
I've seen the involvement
over the years, pretty much.
There's a dish that we do called
Into the Vegetable Garden,
which is on the
menu all the time.
It's on the menu all
the time, and it's
the only dish that's on
the menu all the time,
with the exact same
wording all the time,
but the dish is
different every day.
I know that sounds strange.
But what it is, the rule
is that everything that
comes from Love Apple
Farms on a daily basis,
there has to be an item
of that on this plate.
And if it's not from
Love Apple Farms,
it can't be on this plate.
It's a celebration of this
relationship that we have.
One cynically could say it
looks like a green salad.
But in the handful of bites,
the four to five bites that
are on the plate,
there's anywhere
from 45 to 60 ingredients
on the plate every day.
And it's built up in
the shape of a plant.
There's root vegetable
purees on the bottom,
and there's a cooked set.
Then there's a raw set,
a seed set, a flower set.
If you look at it
from 10 feet away,
it looks like a green salad.
But each leaf is on there.
There's up to 30 leaves
on it, and each one
is from a different plant
or a different vegetable
or a different lettuce or herb.
So each mouthful is different.
And we get deliveries from
the farm three times a week.
And we have two people who
just work on this dish.
That's all they do.
For the 50 people we feed
a night, everybody gets it,
and each one's built to order.
So they spend a lot of
time cleaning and building
these little kits
that come together.
But it never started
out just like this.
It originally
started out, we were
looking for a dish
that represented
the relationship
between the farm.
But when it started out,
it was a lot smaller.
It was only about three acres.
The farm's now 22 acres.
When it started out, there was
a limited amount of produce.
So we were kind of
just doing vegetables.
They had a great
patch of potatoes,
so it started out
as a potato dish
with burrata cheese and
vegetables from the farm.
And then we got rid
of the burrata cheese
because we weren't producing it.
And then we weren't getting
the potatoes year round.
So we were calling
it-- it started out
potatoes and burrata with the
vegetables from the garden.
And then it was just
potatoes with vegetables
from the garden.
And finally, we just
took this plunge
in which we went in
and just called it
Into the Vegetable Garden.
And it became much
more of a concept.
There's even an edible
dirt on the plate we make,
which is made with dehydrated
potatoes and parsnips
and almonds and
roasted chicory root,
which makes it look
like potting soil.
But it's very
delicious potting soil,
and it's sprinkled around
there to represent dirt.
AUDIENCE: Have a favorite dish?
DAVID KINCH: No, I don't
have a favorite dish.
Do I have a favorite dish?
No, I don't.
I mean, I orchestrate
everything.
I got a team of 14
people in the kitchen
for feeding 55 people a night.
They work very hard.
They work 12-hour days.
And I throw a lot of
curveballs at them.
It's like, they'll
come up to a dish.
They'll get into a routine.
And once we're into a routine,
and everything is going really
well with the menu,
that's usually
when I want to change things
and try new ideas and things.
And we do only tasting menus.
We do a six-course menu
and a 14-course menu.
So for me, it's not necessarily
dishes, but it's the meal.
And we look at different
points in the meal.
It's like you have chapters.
You have like an introduction
of flavors, and things rise up.
The garden is kind of like the
climax, the garden dish, which
is right smack in the middle.
And then there's a denouement.
We finish with a
piece of red meat,
but it's not the biggest portion
that you're going to get.
It's actually going
to be the garden
dish in the middle of the meal.
So it kind of slowly descends.
And we then we have desserts.
And we kind of want to
finish like a whisper,
or like really, really
quiet at the end.
And we start with
a dish and finish
with a dish that
looks exactly alike,
but the flavors are
completely different.
The first ones are savory,
and the last ones are sweet.
You can see it in the book.
And it kind of denotes the
full circle of the meal.
So I'm not looking
at specific dishes,
but I'm looking at
an arc of the meal
and how I can tweak the
experience along that arc.
I think if you're
doing a meal that
involves 10, 12, 14
courses, each dish
can't be really,
really complicated
because then you can't
process everything.
Everything needs to be simple
because it all adds up.
And ultimately, if you're eating
an appetizer, main course,
and a dessert at a
restaurant, or you're
eating a 15-course
tasting menu, one
is not bigger than the other.
I still think a
meal should consist
of 25 small bites of food.
You can do it with
three plates of food,
or you can do it with
15 plates of food.
What you're paying for or
what you're looking for
is really a diversity or a
variety of tastes and textures
and experiences.
A lot of people don't want that.
A lot of people want
a plate of food.
They can have six or
seven-- a dish evolves.
You have that first bite.
It's explosive, it's different.
And you enjoy it more,
and you enjoy it more,
and things mix together,
that sort of thing.
I understand that experience.
That's a great experience.
But then there's a
tasting menu, where
you have two or three dishes.
Maybe there's a
little bit of a palate
fatigue after the third bite.
But then you know what?
It's finished.
It's whisked away, and you
have another small sample
that's probably a
little bit different.
Hot dish following a cold
dish, something crispy followed
by something soft,
something vegetal
followed by something that has
real oceanic or saline flavors.
That's kind of how we
look at in the kitchen,
as opposed to individual dishes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID KINCH: He's asking how
increased dietary restrictions
and/or aversions affect
what we do at the restaurant
and how we deal with it.
Funny story, I was cooking
in France at a restaurant.
A great friend of mine has a
great restaurant in France.
I was cooking over there, and
we were doing a special dinner,
and we were cooking.
And an order came back, and it
had some dietary restrictions
on it.
And he turns around and says
to his staff, four Americans
on table 22, because
you'd be amazed
at how much of an American
phenomenon this is.
America has more dietary
restrictions and allergies
than any country on the planet.
Or at least they express
them in a restaurant.
It is extraordinary.
I was saying at lunch today,
35% to 40% of my diners
every night make some
sort of change in the menu
that we're preparing for them
to suit their personal needs.
35% to 40%.
I would say that 80% of
them are not allergies.
They are people who
don't like red peppers,
or they don't want
me to do mushrooms
for them, because they
don't like mushrooms.
And that's fine.
We do what we can.
We don't say no to anybody.
We do everything
within our power.
But my feeling is,
is my restaurant,
at this point, my
price point, in what
we do-- we've worked
very, very hard to craft
a really great,
sensual experience,
a hedonist experience.
We want you to come
in for three hours,
turn off your cell phone, forget
about your frantic lifestyle.
You have a chance to escape.
That's what you're paying
for when you come to Manresa.
We hope you like the food,
but the service, the ambiance,
everything we do is to make
you forget everything and just
really enjoy yourself.
And we're an oasis.
We're an oasis in the
middle of Silicon Valley,
and that's what
you're paying for.
And I like to think
that people come here,
and they kind of put
themselves into our hands
and have them allow us
to do everything possible
we can to crack that experience
because that's what we do.
It's what we do for a living.
But sadly, that's not the case.
And I understand people who
have severe nut allergies
or can't eat peanuts.
But I'll tell you,
I have people who
come in and say they won't
eat food that had a mother.
I have people who
say they won't eat
food that has the
color green in it.
And I'm serious.
They want to do tasting menus.
They want to.
And we have to create 15 to
18 different plates of food
on the fly.
We have to make it up at
the beginning of the meal.
And we do our
best, but we're not
giving them the best
experience we can get.
The worst is the people
who don't-- people call,
make a reservation.
We call to confirm.
We always ask, do you
have any allergies?
Do you have any restrictions?
They're the ones who don't
say anything and then come
in and say they're vegan.
Vegans with nut
allergies, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Tasting menus, tasting menus.
And I'm not trying to denigrate.
I understand.
We're a business.
We want people to come in,
and we want them to be happy.
But it doesn't allow us to craft
the best experience we possibly
can.
Now another thing we were
talking about at lunch today
is we're going to only
one menu in January.
We're making a big
step, and we're
going to offer only
one experience.
We're going to
offer the best menu
that we can put out every night.
But if someone
wants three courses,
we're going to say fine.
We're not going to
say no to anybody.
If someone wants seven
courses, you know,
I've got to be out two hours.
I want to go to a show
at the Mountain Winery--
I need to be out.
I just want to do five courses.
I got a guy who comes to my
restaurant five times a month,
and he only does three courses.
And he buys a lot of wine.
I'm not going to all
the sudden tell him,
you know what, you can't
come to my restaurant
anymore because this-- we're
going to say no to nobody.
That said, for us to
craft the experience,
we have to know every
single bit of information
about the customers that we do.
We feed 300 people a week.
We feed 50 people a night.
We have the opportunity to
know every single person who
comes into the restaurant.
You're not table 22.
You're not table 11.
You're not position two.
You are the so
and so who's here,
and she likes to start with
a Corpse Reviver Number 2.
He doesn't like
mushrooms, and he always
buys red Burgundy, between
$350 and $475 a bottle.
We have all that information.
We gather as much of that
information as we can.
So when people call
for reservations,
what we're going to do is we're
going actually have, believe it
or not, a reservation concierge.
I have to hire someone
full-time at the restaurant
to call people, and
we're going to have
to get all their dietary
restrictions five
days in advance.
We're going to have to do it.
And even though we're
going to do only one menu,
we're going to have
five menus a night.
We're actually going to
go from two to five menus,
because we're going to have to
create the menu that we think
offers the best
Manresa experience.
We're going to have
to do the gluten free.
to do the vegetarian.
We're going to have to
do the no shellfish.
We're going to have to do the
no red meat, except for squab.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KINCH: You know,
it's-- and organize this.
And what we would
like to do is know
what every table
is going to eat.
Every single person
is going to eat,
we want to know at 3
o'clock in the afternoon.
There's no ticket going
to come into the kitchen.
We have the ticket at 3
o'clock in the afternoon.
And you know what,
I think then we
will be able to offer
a great experience.
Talking with other
chefs who do this,
they say they got tired of it.
And it's not because they're
tired of people dictating what
and how they want
to eat, but they
got tired of the
frustration, not
being able to offer their best
experience to the customer.
So he says, I charge
a lot of money,
and I've got to do
this on the fly,
and I don't want to
do this on the fly.
They're still paying
the same money,
and I still want them to
have a great experience.
I want them to come back.
But I can't do it when they
just come in and tell me.
I need to know in advance.
So I think that's really
the only thing we can do.
"Combat it" is the wrong word.
But it's pretty
intense right now.
We have nights where 70% of
the people change their menu.
Like last night.
Last night was like that.
All but four tables last
night had dietary restrictions
that required menu changes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID KINCH: OK.
That's an easy question.
There's absolutely none.
But there's a reason why.
Because our first
restaurant was called
Sent Sovi, which
was in Saratoga.
It's still there.
We had a restaurant
called Sent Sovi,
and Manresa was a relocation
of that restaurant.
And Sent Sovi, when it
originally opened up,
was a Catalan style bistro.
And Sent Sovi was
named after a cookbook.
It was called the
Llibre de Sent Sovi.
And before the discovery
of the New World,
it was the most
influential cooking manual
in all of Europe.
It codified the most famous
recipes in all of Europe.
They drew diagrams
of all the fish
from the Mediterranean and North
Atlantic that were known there
and wrote the flavor
characteristics
and how to break them down.
It was this all-inclusive work.
And it was believed
to have been written
by a bunch of Catalan cooks
who cooked in the English royal
court.
And so we named the
restaurant after this book.
And when we decided
to move to Manresa--
and we slowly morphed away
from this Catalan influence.
We became more and more enamored
with the local ingredients
here in California.
And that's really where we
started to do our focus on.
And when we decided
to relocate, we
found the space
that's now Manresa.
We called it Manresa
as a working title.
Manresa is the name of
the town next to Barcelona
in the Catalan country, the
capital the Catalan country,
where the order of Jesuits
or Junipero Serra was from,
who founded all the--
not Spanish missions,
but the Catalan missions
along the coast of California,
named half the
coast of California.
Junipero Serra, when everything
was actually Catalan,
not Spanish.
So when it actually came
time to name the restaurant,
we couldn't think of anything.
It was actually the
hardest thing to do.
So we kept Manresa.
But the short answer is, it's
a beach south of Santa Cruz,
really close to where we live.
You got the long and
the short answer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID KINCH: Yes,
I mean I admire
all great ambitious chefs.
I learn-- right now,
the most inspiring thing
is traveling and meeting
like-minded chefs
and learning what they do and
eating in their restaurants
and learning what
their viewpoints are.
That's a really big part
of what we do is sharing.
We started bringing
in guest chefs
from all over the world
at Manresa, back in 2007.
Some really great two and
three-star Michelin chefs
from all over, from
Denmark and France
and Spain have
come over to cook.
And it's always been
an exchange of ideas.
And the great thing is, is I
get to go to their restaurant
and cook, too, because
it's always an exchange.
So we like to do that a lot.
Most of my inspiration
nowadays comes
from travel, reading and travel.
Actually, we have a
really great-- May 17
and 18 of next year, we
have this great [INAUDIBLE]
chef, a really young guy, just
got his third Michelin star.
His name's [INAUDIBLE],
and he cooks
in the middle of
the Basque country.
He has a big garden.
His restaurant's
surrounded by the garden.
He cooks completely
from his garden.
And he's coming to cook
with us May 17 and 18
of next year, which is going
to be a really amazing event,
and he's cooking for two days.
So I'm pretty excited about it.
That's a great example of
what you're talking about.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID KINCH: What do I do
for the creative process?
Well, I have to be honest.
It's mostly ingredients.
We'll get one thing.
We'll have access
to one thing that's
really special and
really perfect.
It could be an eggplant.
It could be a piece of fish,
could be a piece of meat.
It could be a piece of
fruit from a great purveyor,
and we know we only have two
or three weeks to work with it.
And what we do is we try
and create everything
around the fundamental flavor
and the characteristics
of that one, and everything
else is kind of like a satellite
off that.
I talk a little bit
about that in the book.
We try to have like three
elements on a plate.
We have a main element and
then a secondary element
that offers a certain sense
of comfort or knowledge
to everyone.
It could be like meat and
potatoes or tomato and basil,
something like that,
something that there
is an obvious connection.
It doesn't have to be
an obvious connection,
but it seems like an
obvious connection.
And then the third
element is usually
something jarring
or contrasting.
It could be a
temperature contrast.
When it comes down to
having a finished dish,
and we're doing
the editing process
before it goes on the
menu, our process is not,
what else can we add to
this to finish this plate?
It's, what can we take off?
You're stripping
things of the plate
until it's still complete, but
there's nothing else on there.
we try to leave things as bare
and as simple as possible.
That's going back to the
tasting menu format, too.
We don't want it to be
15 complicated dishes.
It needs to be 15 simple dishes.
Oh, how was your
meal at Manresa?
It was great.
But what'd you eat?
I don't really remember,
because it was just
this barrage of
complicated dishes.
You want things to be
simple and to stand out.
And the second question
was cookbook about--
AUDIENCE: How do
you hope users will
approach the
cookbook [INAUDIBLE]?
DAVID KINCH: How do I hope
people will use the cookbook?
A couple things about the
cookbook, none of the recipes
are dumbed down.
Everything is exactly how
we do it at the restaurant.
There are no shortcuts.
That said, there are tons of
really simple recipes in there,
believe it or not.
Tons of simple recipes, and
then recipes of more ambition.
And what I would
hope people would do
is they try some of the simple
recipes, or recipes they feel
is in their skill
set or skill level.
And I think even the most basic
cooks, there's several things.
And then if it
works out, then you
work on to more ambitious
recipes and try.
A lot of the more
complicated recipes
are sometimes just a
series of components.
Some of the more
complicated desserts,
there might be a
cookie and a cake
and a custard and an ice cream.
And you don't have to
make the whole dessert.
The cookie, cake, the
ice cream, they're
all standalone
components that are
simple and easily approachable.
So you can break things down.
And the recipes are
written that way.
But the other thing
that is-- Ten Speed
was great in writing
this cookbook,
in giving me almost
everything I wanted.
The one thing I had
a little bit of push
back on in the beginning,
and it was really
the only thing I
really insisted upon--
and the chefs in this room will
know what I'm talking about--
is that we went to the metric
system, and we went to weights.
I said, I'm not going to
do imperial measurements,
and I'm not going to do volumes.
And they said, you have to
because the American public is
really dumb, and they gotta
cook like their grandmother.
They gotta have a cup
of flour to bake a cake.
You measure things
out in a cup of flour.
Well, you know what?
A cup of flour on a
rainy day and a cup
of flour on a dry, hot day
weigh completely different.
They weigh 10% in weight.
10% will screw up
the recipe of baking.
But 450 grams of flour weighs
450 grams on a wet day,
on a cold day, on a dry day.
So weight, we weigh
water in kitchens.
A liter of water
weighs 1,000 grams.
It's easy.
It's really easy.
If you weighed--
the best chef, what
is the best kitchen
tool in your kitchen?
What do you recommend is
the one thing I can use?
A kitchen scale, a
digital kitchen scale.
They cost $15.
You put it on.
You make a cake.
Instead of measuring volumes of
flour and cracking eight eggs
and measuring out 8 and
1/2 ounces of sugar,
you put a bowl.
You hit the tare.
You put in your flour.
You put in the eggs.
You hit the tare.
You put in the flour.
Instead of getting four things
dirty, you get one thing dirty.
It's faster.
It's cleaner.
It's more efficient.
It's more accurate.
It's a win-win-win-win
situation.
It's so easy.
Metric system
changes everything.
Weights change it.
Guys, am I right?
People say-- if you take
one thing from the book.
Oh, you know, your
book is so ambitious.
What is the one thing
that we can take from it?
The one thing you can
take from it is, is we
weigh ingredients in the
professional kitchen.
You should weigh
ingredients at home,
if you're going
to follow recipes.
Weigh them.
And it's happening.
You're seeing more
and more recipes.
Right now, you're seeing
imperial measurements
with the metric weights
behind it in parentheses.
In my book, it's
metric and the weight
with the-- our compromise
was the imperials
are in parentheses.
In 5, 10 years,
you're going to see
nothing but metric and weight.
Get used to it.
It's so much easier.
You're going to be
shocked at how easy it is.
Don't measure out a
cup of flour anymore.
Weigh out 227 grams of flour.
Lots of reading.
Pre-internet, you know,
you read a lot of books,
and you save your money.
And you travel, and
you eat at restaurants.
Because nowadays, you want
to go eat at a restaurant,
you can see a 20-course menu,
25 different 20-course menus
from a restaurant.
And believe it or
not, I avoid that.
I avoid it because
it's pollution.
You see so much images, so
much food from so many--
it pollutes the ability
to create your own style.
If I want to go eat
at Noma in Copenhagen,
I'm not going to obsess
about 15 bloggers
posting all 25 courses
they had at the meal.
It's too jarring.
It muddles everything.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
The thing to do is to
go to Noma and eat,
because a photo's not
going to tell you anything.
A restaurant is not
just about the food.
A great restaurant experience
is about the entire experience.
It's the ambiance, the food,
your mood when you go in,
who you're dining
with, the weather.
And we only worry
about the things
that we can control, which
is food, service, ambiance.
Greeting-- you come
into the restaurant,
we make eye contact,
and we smile at you.
And it better be genuine
because that's it.
Genuine smile.
No fake smiles.
No, you know what
I'm talking about.
You know what I'm
talking about .
Every person that comes into the
restaurant, the service staff
makes eye-- you don't
see that in a blog post.
You don't see that
in a blog post.
Chefs who obsess, I can
go into a restaurant,
and I can see a chef,
and I know what cookbooks
are on the shelves, what
internet sites they look at,
how old they are, where they
work, whose chefs they admire.
That's what the
internet has done.
Now I'm not saying
that as a bad thing.
There's obviously very,
very good things about it.
Research, learning
about ingredients,
that sort of thing.
But this obsessive,
real-time Instagramming
of food all the way through,
in my mind, is [INAUDIBLE].
It causes blockage in
my ability to create .
We try to make it as
collaborative as possible.
We meet every quarter.
We try to work about
three seasons ahead.
Right now, I'm going
to be meeting her
for fall of next year, spring
and summer for next year.
We make a pot of coffee,
stretch out with seed catalogs,
and we talk about what we
had last year at that time,
what worked, what didn't
work, what we want more of,
what we want less of, new
things we want to try,
things we don't want to grow
anymore, and new varieties.
It's a clearly
collaborative effort.
I think the big challenging
thing at Love Apple--
and it took us the
longest time to do--
was to cut some
[INAUDIBLE] specifically
for the restaurant.
At the beginning, I don't know
who gardens here, or zucchini.
You know, we had way
too much zucchini.
You don't need much.
You don't need many plants.
And we had way too
much salad greens,
but we had these big gaps in
carrots, onions, and leeks.
We'd have it for three
weeks, and then we
wouldn't have anything
for six weeks.
But what we had done is
fine tuned working together
on what the restaurant wants
and what our needs are,
our basic needs are, and what
we want to do to collaborate.
And we've drawn the
correct amounts.
And now we grow the
correct amount of sorrel.
Now we don't gap on
carrots, that sort of thing.
And to me, that's
really impressive,
what she has done at the
farm to make that happen.
And that said, she
always has a couple
of things growing on her on,
for her own interests, that she
likes to present to me and,
what do you think of this?
Well, that's great.
Let's work with it.
We also have a lot of
seed exchange going
on with different people,
Japan, France, Spain, Italy.
Exchange seeds.
Try new things, new product.
Because a lot of the
complexity of our dishes
are heirloom varieties,
really simple but carefully
grown and hopefully well cooked.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]